she's suing us for over 100 million
dollars and we're leaving our fate in
the hands of 12 random people what if
they hate us
khloe kardashian addressing her fear
surrounding the family's lawsuit against
blac chyna what is in the media is sort
of things that we feel we need to film
because it's
in a way unfair to the viewers if they
don't get to see that
yeah and now fans are getting a glimpse
of the kardashians season 2 and their
legal battle with rob kardashian's
former flame will be front and center
you'll recall chyna sued the family for
a hundred million dollars in 2017 for
allegedly scheming to have her rob and
china reality tv show canceled after one
season as a form of revenge for leading
rob go to your phone
through my phone there's nothing i mean
don't you think that's shady you said my
mom or something about me i don't want
you to be i'm gonna go read your convos
with your mom so what are you trying to
read who do you think i'm texting what
do you think i'm doing nearly five years
later back in april the trial finally
took place and it lasted two weeks
in the end a jury ruled that no monetary
damages should be awarded to china
congratulations we just received the
news about today i'm just glad it's over
but it's not completely over as fans
will get to see the behind the scenes of
it all when the show returns to hulu on
september 22nd she's suing us for over
100 million dollars and we're leaving
our fate in the hands of 12 random
people what if they hate us
i love that
the episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and i think that you
have a real insight into what the girls
are doing not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes it's
just so interesting to see it from the
inside out and really get a glimpse of
what happens and how they all balance
what they do because before you would
see little snippets of something and now
i think the episodes are
you know fuller of content that shows
the whole story as for if we'll be seen
robbed next season for now that's
unclear he definitely is more low-key
than all of us and we love that and
respect that
we know his main focus over the years
has been his and china's five-year-old
daughter dream
a source told et at the time of the
trial that rob was trying to keep things
as routine and normal as possible for
her while all that was going on the
source added that he wants to be present
and make sure his little girl feels
secure and safe despite the family drama
flash forward a few months rob and dream
are living their best lives on a
tropical vacation together
[Music]
over the weekend the father-daughter duo
traveled with chloe her daughter true
and kim's daughter chicago for coco's
38th birthday getaway
[Music]
rob shared these adorable pics of his
baby girl with the caption paradise with
dream hashtag camp coco
[Music]